yo what am I wearing you want to know
about my pants right so I guess the big
question there is why is someone like me
who does not strictly need work wear
because I sit at a desk all day like
wearing a pair of work pants you know
they they do everything I need them to I
don't have to worry about them the more
beat-up they get the better they are
these are a pair of Carhartt
double knee the work pants stand rate
carpenter pants very good for installing
drywall and also wearing all summer long
this is a pair of Dickies they're the
classic Dickies the the 874 what are
they eight seven four I don't actually
know the numerical code
I just know them as my Dickies pants so
the reason I love a pair of Dickies and
a pair work pants generally is because
they're like the most basic
old-fashioned idea of a pant you can
have right so they're gonna be a little
higher in the rise and they're gonna be
a straighter sort of buy and bag to your
leg then you might expect from something
that you've had before you look
somewhere between construction worker
and very cool skateboarder they fit
perfectly sort of in this Venn diagram
of where you have like work wear and
skater fashion is so cool any well so
just have like this weird era of pants
where we're trying new things and we're
not just sticking to our normal skinny
denim that's been in style for probably
over a decade the fit is great it's just
kind of where we are right now where
things a little easier a little wider I
actually don't know the origin of these
pants or much about them but what I do
know is that this color brown is
trademarked by Carhartt it's kind of
like a tobacco II thing so kudos to them
for creating a dope hue sand raised just
ended up fitting me really well I like
them a little loosened blousy good for
aerating if I had to like jump off a
building or something I'm sure it would
slow my ball it's very democratic very
affordable I think these are like 30
bucks you can get the keys Amazon for
$20 I think it is for $20 they're crazy
durable I don't do anything like cool
but I'd like
them on certain just like running into
stuff being clumsy and I think they look
kind of cool Vita these payments are $50
as far as wavy pants go it's pretty
cheap you can find a pair of cheaper
pants but they're probably not as cool
as these the best part about cheap pants
is you can make them your own I've done
something really stupid with these
Dickies which is spend more money
getting them tailored then I spent by I
get them tapered from the knee down
pretty aggressively and then I have them
cropped I think you don't really need to
get them tailor they're supposed to fit
like kind of loose kind of baggy and
supposed to be casual and I cuff mine
for length my legs are super short so I
like to roll them up and staple them in
a place it's a trick I learned in Long
Beach Poly back in high school shout-out
to you guys just staple your jeans one
of my favorite things about these pants
in particular is they have the very
perfect cell phone pocket they have a
lot of pockets for hiding things little
babe action here I saw them with
anything today I wore them with like
these kind of like fancy gray socks and
my loafers they almost look like
trousers like you could wear them with
something nice you could wear them with
a nice button up and take them to dinner
and I don't think anyone would be the
wiser you know I've made like a goofy
fake suit out of these with just a
blazer if any of them till you just
style work pants with like a blazer or
something they're trying entirely too
hard I don't want to see you succeed
don't listen to
you can absolutely pull these pants off
they just look like you've listened it
up a little bit and I think that they go
great with everything oh just do it get
yourself a pair of sand rays painter
pants roll them up staple them cut them
you know and do whatever you will paint
a masterpiece go if you'd like a car so
you want to wear some work pants if I
all means to do it just like if somebody
too pretty was wearing a pair of cars I
wouldn't believe it if you think I'm too
handsome and too pretty for a pair of
carts at school today
you